Or the primary objective of the World
Bank is to help developing countries
grow and develop.
And our main objective is to help
countries reduce poverty.
So the World Bank has a long history of
working in China on different types of
projects that have helped reduce
poverty.
Uh,
but personally I interpret this mandate
quite broadly.
I moved to China three years ago for
this assignment and I've come to think
that the key challenge that China faces
is really environmental management,
natural resource scarcity,
you know,
water,
energy,
these key resource issues.
So I think that the impressive poverty
reduction that China has achieved is not
going to be sustainable unless China
really comes to grip with these
environmental challenges.
So on a practical level,
I've tried to shift our World Bank
program to support a lot of different
environmental activities in China,
in the water sector,
developing new energy sources.
You know,
for example,
we financed the first big wind power
wind power station in China and
demonstrated that this is economically
viable.
We finance different types of clean
energy technologies.
So I guess I see what I'm doing is
working with Chinese partners to help
them address some of their key
challenges and,
and that goes beyond environment.
But a lot of our work now is focused on
the environmental area.